chapter 17 is on
applications of constrained least
squares
each of the applications in itself is
like a huge field you can take whole
courses multiple courses on them
but it's just to show you it's it's a
very very simple introduction and you
can actually do something with
constrained least squares
so our first one is going to be on
portfolio optimization in
finance okay so
here's the the setting is this is that
uh we're gonna have uh we're gonna
invest a total of v
dollars uh v is positive um
in and different assets so these could
be different stocks bonds etfs i mean it
actually doesn't matter what they are
over some period could be a day
week month i mean this doesn't matter
now our investments can include
short positions now a short position is
essentially owning
a negative amount of something and what
it means is
you borrow the asset for example
a share of google stock i borrow it
sell it immediately so i receive cash
but now i have the obligation
to repay uh or to pay back to return
one share of google uh later at some
point
so that's the that's it and it turns out
that's that's pretty much equivalent
to owning a negative share of google
at first it sounds strange and it is
strange um but
that that's what it is okay now
um we can describe our portfolio um
by a portfolio allocation weight vector
w okay
and this is relatively common uh
notation
and what it does is w i or wj
gives you the fraction of your total
portfolio value that you hold in
asset j um and uh
that means for example that capital v
that's your
your total portfolio value in dollars um
times w j that gives you the dollar
value
of how much you hold of asset j okay
now um well by by construction uh w
one transpose w which is the sum of the
weights is is one
and that's that's why they're what
that's why it's supposed to be a weight
vector right it's something that adds up
to one
now they're not necessarily uh
non-negative
uh the the entries they could be
negative and when you see a negative one
that simply means
a short position in fact the the
term uh for a portfolio that doesn't
contain
uh negative weights or short positions
is long only because you can have a
short position and a long position
long position means you actually own the
thing um and so
a long only portfolio is one where the w
all the entries in w are non-negative
okay so here's a very specific example
with
three assets um i have my weight vectors
minus 0.2
0.0 1.2 notice that the weights do sum
up to 1.
okay and what does this mean well it
means that we actually take a short
position of 0.2
capital v that's in in dollars in asset
1.
we don't hold any of asset 2. that's
what this 0 means here and then
in in asset 3 we hold 1.2 times our
value
so so roughly speaking what happened is
we we sold asset one that we don't even
have
used the proceeds to buy more of asset
three
than well even then the total value of
our portfolio
right so uh so that's kind of the idea
now obviously
you would only have a portfolio like
that if you thought for some reason
um you know the first asset was going to
go
down in value and the third asset was
going to go up
and the reason that is pretty simple
there that
if the first asset goes down in value
then later when i make good on my
obligation to return
the short position or close out the
short position is how people would say
it
it's cheaper for me so i've made money
on that and if
the third asset goes up then when i sell
it
i'm going to do well so anyway that's
the basic idea
okay so um the there's a concept of
leverage um and uh actually there's
several different
definitions of leverage and as far as i
can tell all
are used so and you know just it's no
big deal you just have to ask
somebody when they say the leverage is
you know to
what they mean which definition are they
using so
here's the definition we'll use because
it's simple it's the sum
of the absolute values of the weights
okay so that's that's the idea
um i mean another definition that's
quite common is our l
minus one then divided by two so um
and you'll and and i think both are used
um
now use i'll you know henceforth use our
definition of leverage
um so capital l the leverage is one when
all the weights are non-negative because
when the weights are non-negative the
absolute values up here
are actually equal to the w you don't
need the absolute values because they're
all non-negative
and then l is the sum of the w's but
that's one so
and that's that's the smallest the
leverage could be so that that that's a
uh that's a long only uh portfolio this
tells you the leverage is one
um some people would say you are
unleveraged right
so um leverage generally means if it's
bigger than one it means at least one of
the weights
is is less than zero means you hold a
short position and
by leverage what it means is you pretty
much you've sold some assets whichever
ones you're holding
short and use the proceeds to to pile
more money into other investments
that's kind of the idea behind
leveraging okay
oh another portfolio that comes up is
the so-called whatever end
portfolio or in our language the ones
over end
portfolio and that's also called the
uniform portfolio and it's basically
like
you know yeah if you've got 10 assets
put 10
of the total value in all of them that's
it
okay um now another common assumption
is that we'll often assume that asset
and
some people use asset one doesn't matter
is risk free is the way people would say
that
and that's another way to say that
people also say cash
or treasury bills the idea being is that
there's
not is that there's not much risk in
treasury uh bills
um okay so that's uh that's like asset
and is
is a special one it's risk-free um
that's just kind of interesting
at some point all these things start
sounding the same that's very much it
like in regression
or something when i'm building a model
and my first basis function is the ones
vector right uh so
my first basis function is the constant
function one and so that one is special
it's a constant and we'll see that
that's kind of what this is as well
um so with with that assumption w
if you have w equals e n it says put all
of your
zero of your portfolio on assets one to
n minus one
and put 100 of your portfolio value on
asset n
if asset n is cash then you'd say well
that's the portfolio is in all cash
okay so it's just some basics okay
um now we'll talk about the return over
a period
so what we'll do is we'll let r tilde
sub j
it's going to be the return of asset
j over the period and
it's we'll define that as the fractional
increase
in the price or value um and
it's a decrease if it's if it's negative
right if the return is negative it means
it decreased in value
and it's often expressed as a percent
like you know plus 1.1 or minus 2.3 so
if you say the return was minus 2.3
percent
it means that you know you for every
dollar you put in uh
the value at the end of the period was
whatever it would be
so 97 point uh i guess 97.7
uh cents okay so that's that's what that
means
now your portfolio value uh
also changes um over over the investment
period
and we're going to call the after
investment period value of your
portfolio v
plus and the uh
the initial portfolio as v so
v plus is v plus minus v is the increase
in value of your portfolio now it could
be negative right which means you lost
money
but or lost value um if if uh
but it's that's what it is it's simply
the increase and i'm not saying it
necessarily increases but it's the
increase in
the value of the portfolio and i divide
that by the initial value
and then that is the fractional increase
in the value of the portfolio
that's called a portfolio return and it
turns out that is exactly simply
artillery
transpose w where artillery is the
is the fractional uh is the return the
vector that gives you the fractional
returns of all the assets
right so here he goes just in other
words we're back to week one of the
class it's just an inner product
so if you have you know the weights in a
product in
taking the inner product of the weights
with the fractional returns of the
assets
individual assets gives you the
fractional increase in value or the
return
of the whole portfolio just inner
product okay
now what happens is if you hold a
portfolio
for t periods and and the returns over
that periods are r1
r2 r3 and so on um then
the value at the end of the period is
this uh
it it's actually take a product of its
v1 times 1 plus r1 times 1 plus r2
you know and so on uh so that that's
that's the actual uh
value of of the portfolio right so and
this is you know this is if i tell you
look
i put in a million dollars and then it
goes up five percent
then down seven then up three then up
six then down two you know that kind of
thing then
the value at the end is going to look
like that so because you just you just
each time you're just multiplying by one
plus the return
okay and for some reason that's
historical
and that i don't know the origin of uh
portfolio values
versus time are traditionally plotted
using uh from an initial portfolio of
ten thousand
dollars i i don't know why but i it's
just
it's a number maybe from the sixties or
i have no idea what it is but
that's what it is i mean so you'll see
that but you'll see everything else
you'll see people start with a dollar or
something
and and of course if you if you it's
linear in that amount right so if i
double the amount you put in initially
then the total value at the end is
double that so
okay so in terms of that doesn't matter
but just so you know you're going to see
things that are referenced to ten
thousand dollars at the beginning
and you might ask why and the answer is
well two things number one i don't know
and number two it's historical for sure
okay
so uh this brings us to the return
matrix so
suppose uh we're gonna hold a portfolio
with weights w over t periods
okay so this is the the setting um and
we're going to define
uh a an asset return matrix which is
going to be
t uh by n so here's t
and and i i've drawn it as if it's uh
tall
um that's often the case but not always
right so we could we could easily have
uh oh uh i should say that the asset the
group of all the assets you're investing
in
i'll teach you some slang is called the
investment
universe so n is the size of the
universe of assets and so it would be
like you'd be the kind of things people
would say what's your universe and the
person would come back and say
i don't know u.s whatever high cap or
who knows that kind of thing anyway
there you know you now you know another
slang word okay so
all right so we make this return matrix
r
um and it's t by n um now
the rows uh correspond to uh periods
time periods and you know a very common
thing would be a day
right but i mean none of this the math
works if this is every one minute if
it's every week quarter
year it doesn't really doesn't matter um
but let's just
i'll continue talking speaking as if uh
it's
we're talking about daily stuff okay so
so each
row here um is going to be is actually
the transpose
of the return vector over period t
so those are the uh that's that's the
row so a row here would tell you
how did all you the assets do on that
particular day
okay now column is super interesting a
column
focuses on a single asset and it tells
you the time series of its returns
okay so that's what that is
now the portfolio return
time series is simply well it's it's
matrix vector multiplication you
multiply
this matrix um by the weight vector w
and you get rw and that is that's your
that's your that's a time
series so little r is a time series
capital t
long of the portfolio return so if you
looked at it it would say it would be
minus .01
plus 0.02 minus you know 0.005
you know and that means it kind of you
know went down a percent that went
up two percent then down half a percent
that kind of thing okay
um all right so um
if the if the last asset is risk free
which we're going to assume
then the last column uh is the that's
the return
series of that risk free asset um and
what that is it's very simple it is
simply mu risk free which is a number
uh times ones in other words it's
constant
so that's what it means to be risk-free
i mean if you like you can set roux
sorry mu risk free equal to what is
you know one or whatever and then it
just means it's like putting
whatever dollars you know under the
mattress or something it just
nothing happens but uh what it really
means is it goes up
now by the way interest rates at the
time this is 2020 interest rates are
like super low so
it might as well be zero frankly but uh
in any case that's what that's the idea
is that
is that you get the interest rate um on
if it's daily
uh you know one day's interest so which
is extremely small right now but
it's fine um okay and that's called the
risk-free per
period interest rate um that's and you
know it makes perfect sense i mean
if you scan well first of all the
standard deviation of that column
is zero because it's constant and
that's actually kind of that's going to
be one of our definitions of risk
is you know how much does a return vary
and that last column
it's zero and that's why we call it
risk-free now you look if
there's another column in there which is
tesla or google or something like that
you'll see it be positive negative
positive who knows what it is right it's
varying all around
and that's of course not risk-free
okay so um
so here i get a i'm going to get a time
series that's a vector a portfolio
returns no it depends on w and we're
going to go into great detail
about about that later but for right now
we just say
depends on it it's it's w is fixed it
doesn't matter
how you got it doesn't matter um so and
but once you fix
w you get a time series of portfolio
returns that that's r
here i could plot it i could do all
sorts of stuff now
the average return or or people just say
the return is the average of that
so that's the average return um and the
risk
is the standard deviation so the
standard deviation the risk of your
portfolio
says how variable is the portfolio
return that's really bad that's what the
standard deviation measures and so
if it's zero uh which would be the case
if w
equals en that means put the entire
portfolio into the risk-free thing
then the risk is zero because the
portfol the return
is mu risk-free and the standard
standard deviation is zero because
every single day you you earn exactly mu
risk free
so uh so that's that that's what they're
that's and that's what people call uh
risk
okay um now
they're related to the increase in value
uh not directly i've not not
it's not like it's equal to it but
here's the analysis
it says um if you look at what is vt
plus one that that's
that's what's the value of your
portfolio you know t basically if you
propagate forward t
time steps from uh from from one
right your initial time step and it's
equal to this it's v one and well you
remember it's the initial value times
and then you just simply multiply
by all the the returns right oh by the
way some people refer to this process of
multiple
of taking the product of one plus things
as compounding
right so it's a it's it means kind of if
you if
if if you get if you do well you you
reinvest
right but for us that's kind of that's
what the weight vector means
now this i'm going to expand this now
and
the first term i get is when i multiply
all the ones together in this big
product here
and that's going to give me v1 then i
get v1 and the next term
is when i get in all of these i multiply
i take
all of the ones except one of them and
then i take one of the r's
and that's going to give me this this
term here now what's missing
i can tell you what i have neglected in
that approximation
i've neglected all the terms where
there's products like you know
r three times r seven and in fact
there's even like even bigger ones
the argument goes like this if r is on
the order
of like you know one one percent um
something you know but just roughly
right if r is on the order of a percent
or something
it's 0.01 and so this thing
makes sense here um but when you
multiply
you know two quantities on the order of
0.01 you get something that's 10 to the
minus 4
and it's basically negligible so um
okay so that's the approximation being
made here and that says that your value
at um at you know if you go capital t
periods in the future it's basically
your initial value
plus your initial value times this
number which is t
times the average return right so so the
basic idea is it tells you that the
average
return tells you something about the
increase in portfolio value
value over that period and you know look
if the returns are ridiculous things
like plus minus you know 0.15.2
then this is kind of a crappy
approximation but nevertheless it's a
good one for
in fact for a lot of situations actually
very good one
oh and the only thing i should say about
that is this tells you
why you would want the return
to be large i mean it look it's kind of
obvious why you'd want the return to be
large
this quantifies it it basically says it
has to it it has to do with an
approximation
that tells you about your um your
increase
in in value over some period okay
so um usually both risk and return for a
financial
uh return time series are uh are not
quoted as
as you know per day or per week or per
month or whatever you're doing
they're all they're all converted to
what what it would be over a year
um and that's called annualized and that
way it's easier right if i say what's
the return on that thing and you go
not so bad it's 15 what they mean is
it's 15
over a year what's the risk on it that's
also given as 12 percent over a year
okay something like that all right so um
so the way you do that uh is the
annualized return that's an easy
calculation you simply multiply
if there's p periods per year
then you simply multiply it so if this
is weekly that might be
52 right if it's daily there's about
let's see there's about 250 maybe closer
to 252
trading days in a year obviously it
depends on
the market and all that kind of stuff so
it can be more less i mean it can be all
sorts of stuff
but that's a p it would be about 250
there is a good approximation of it
if it's daily trading um the annualized
risk is interesting you don't multiply
by
p actually what you do is you take the
standard dev
sorry the uh the variance and you
multiply
that you multiply by p standard
deviation is the square root of that
and so you actually have to take the
square root of p
so it says that the annualized risk is
the square root of p so that's about 16
or something like that if it's if you
have 250
and it says if you had 250 trading days
a year your annualized return
right would be 250 times the average of
the daily return
and your annualized risk would be square
250 and you know what if it's not 250
it's 252 or 251 you know go ahead and
fix
this is just to give you a rough idea of
what it is okay so
so this is just if i'm just saying if
you go and read a book on finance or
something like that
these are the this is what you're going
to see and it kind of makes sense right
because
otherwise it's hard to in your head
people are going to do this calculation
in their head anyway
so this is how people quote things okay
we now come that's all the preliminaries
and we now come
to the main question here which is how
should we choose
this the weights um should we just make
it uniform
that's that's uh the one over n
portfolio other
or uh written in math it's w equals ones
over n uh which i mean what should be w
right um now we have two
uh desiderata so there's two things that
we want here um
the first is we want we want high mean
portfolio return and we want low
portfolio risk so this is a bi-objective
problem i mean immediately we can see
that
it's a it's a problem involving we want
the mean to be high and we want the risk
to be low
um now
the tricky part you know i'm sure
someone has said this
the tricky part is of course you you
don't know what the returns are going to
be in the future
by the way if you did you don't need any
of this
to do very well so yeah if you had it
if you had the possibility of knowing
future returns you could do very well
without
this okay um so we don't know that but
here's what we do know
um we do know we we know let's say for
example last year's
returns because it's it's historical
record we can go look it up
um so of course we don't know next
year's returns
right i i should add you know that's
basically what happens if you walk into
a hedge fund that's basically what
people are doing is they're trying to
figure out what are
you know what are next year's returns
not just hedge funds
i mean any kind of any kind of people
and anyone putting together a portfolio
is basically doing that they're trying
to figure out you know what's going to
happen to tesla
might be in the next hour might be in
the tomorrow or 10 days from now and it
might be
you know quarter by quarter okay
so so we don't know the future basically
um but we do know the past
um and so here's the idea and it's this
we're going to choose a weight vector
that would have worked well
on past returns that's what we're going
to do
and this is and this is a matter of
faith which is
not always well-founded or whatever
and we're simply going to hope that it
is going to
work well going forward so that is going
to be the approach
um now it sounds weird uh
and we'll get we'll get to just how
weird it is but i do want to point out
it's not
it's not i mean that's exactly what we
do on data fitting right if you do data
fitting and someone says what are you
doing you'd say
well i'm fitting a model and you go well
what do you really want to do you oh
well i wanted to be able to predict you
know starting next week i wanted to be
able to predict demand for my product
and they were like well how are you
doing you go oh well i'm i'm using this
data from last year
and they're like yeah but the demand
last year is not the demand
next year you go yeah i know anyway so
i'm just saying
data fitting is very is very similar and
we'll get to what the essential
the essential assumption is something
like that
yeah but if if the way demand varied
last year is the same as how it
continues to
vary this year then a model built on
last year's demand data should be pretty
good for next year
right or something like that right so
it's the same thing in
in finance maybe with more surprises i i
would say
okay so uh we are going to get to
portfolio optimization now
it is in fact a constrained least
squares
problem at least in our formulation of
it so here's how we're going to do it
um we are remember we have two desired
we want
high return which is the average of
little r um and we want low
uh risk and the risk
is the standard deviation variance which
is the square of that
okay so here's what we're going to do
what we're going to do is we
are going to specify
a required return row
that's it so if row is 0.1 it means
we are requiring a a um
we are requiring a return of uh
of row of ten percent that's it um
okay um now then
the what we're going to do is we're then
going to minimize the variance
of the of of the time series little r
this is little r which is the portfolio
return
now the variance of something is uh
basically um that's not the yeah it's
the
variance is the mean square deviation
from the mean
okay so normally but the point is we're
actually
requiring the mean to be rho so um
it's like okay so we just put that here
so so the point is that the
standard deviation of rw squared is you
know
which is the mean square uh
deviation from the mean that's given by
this expression here
now rho is given r is data
uh so and in our job of course the
variable that we're going to find out
that we want to seek is w the the weight
vector
um the first constraint which is linear
the linear constraint
equality constraint says that that w
sums to one well that's kind of by
definition so that's fine
and the second one here is the one that
says
um i want the average return at least
historically to have been wrong so
that's the idea
so let's see let me talk about some of
these things here i think we've talked
about most of these things
um uh oh when you any
here you can vary row and you'll get
different portfolios
and in fact you can even think about
what row is um row
tells you it's the required return and
the larger it gets basically people
would say
the more aggressive your portfolio is
because you're basically
saying give me import if you say give me
a portfolio that had 50
return it'll do it it'll do it by doing
crazy stuff and shorting stuff and
having high leverage but it'll do it
okay so that that's the that's the idea
um okay and so to be very precise about
what we're doing when we solve this
problem is we're really
asking what would have been the
best constant allocation had we known
future returns
now that's a bit silly because
um i mean on its face it's utterly
useless
because you know if if in fact
i if i knew the returns if i knew the
returns over the next year over the last
year and they went back in time
um i wouldn't do this that's for sure uh
if i do the returns i could actually
make a bundle of money because i
i'd buy stuff that i know was going to
go up and i'd short stuff that was going
to go down and blah blah blah
so anyway so but that that's what we're
doing to be very precise
uh we are finding a portfolio that would
have worked
last year i mean roughly right um
kind of weird but that's that's what it
is i mean look it's not any weirder than
data fitting frankly
because our job is to make something
that works on data we've never seen
um and to do that we use data that we
have seen
right so you know and then someone comes
along and says
we have last year's data you go yeah i'm
using it to estimate
you know why and they go but you know
why why do you need to estimate it right
you get the idea but this is similar
okay now um now we can this is just a
this is a constrained
least squares problem period right
because you know
i can put everything in the form with
the whatever the you know
norm ax minus b squared subject to cx
equals d
c has two rows there are two linear
equality constraints
that's the the weight constraint
and also the average return constraint
so we're going to write it this way it
is identical to what we had before
you know i did a few things like i
dropped the one over t because
if i if i change the objective by a
factor it doesn't change anything and it
just lightens the notation so there it
is
looks like that and here oh i should say
what mu
is mu is r transpose 1 divided by t
that is the that is the vector of the
mean
returns of each of the n
assets right so that that's what that
tells you what that is right
row again is a parameter that we choose
oh and we're going to vary because when
we vary it we just get different
portfolios with different levels of
aggressiveness
and of course that's an equality
constrained least squares problem and
here's the solution
that's the kkt matrix and
this is the right hand side here
so it's w you get these two lagrange
multipliers
we actually don't care about them but we
are interested in w
right this is an n plus two vector here
um
and so we simply solve this least
squares problem constrain this
correspond
any way we like you know and for all i
care just make up you know in your code
just make a backslash and you're done
um okay so that that's it um
oh i could let's we could we could
actually name a few things just to make
this uh
uh i mean in some cases we can do this
we can say what the solution is
just analytically or by inspection so
here's an example
if i set row equals row risk free
then what this says is please go back
last year
and find me a portfolio of investments
whose average return is the risk-free
return
oh and also i'd like you to minimize the
variance of the return
but you know what the solution to that
is just going to be this
it's going to be w equals e n it's going
to be
the it's going to be put everything in
the last asset which is cash
let me tell you why because if you use
this then
the portfolio return is simply row risk
free
times ones oh so cool that's the average
we win
right so we we do that oh also the
variance is
zero it is after all risk free right
so that means it's just not there's no
risk um oh yeah and by the way norms
words don't come smaller than zero so
that is optimal for sure so
i'm just saying that that's an
interesting point on that uh on this
curve as we check now for other rows
that's not the solution
you know it's going to be something very
different but i just want to mention
that that's a that's an important
special point that where we can just
tell you what the solution is
no kkt equations you know not but of
course
if you were to assemble and solve the
kkt equations with rho equals risk free
that's a good homework problem by the
way you i hope you get back en
that's uh well if you don't your code is
wrong
okay so um
so these optimal portfolios when you put
them together you know they
they perform significantly better than
individual assets uh in terms of risk
and return
right so they'll they'll be um they will
be
they'll have either lower risk for the
same level of return or higher return
for the same level of risk
they'll simply be better than the
individual assets
now when you plot and you vary row
remember row row is the thing that
modulates it's the parameter that
modulates how aggressive our portfolio
is um as we
change row uh we get a portfolio and
it turns out it forms a straight line
and the reason is
if you look at this formula right here
you will see
you will see that w
uh well i go back to this formula back
here
and you say how does this depend on row
well look at this
the right hand side has got rho in the
first and the third
block entry right so
it turns out you can just check i mean
well matrix vector multiplication is
linear or whatever so it looks like this
it says that we can express it this way
now this that's just a fixed
portfolio um that's another fixed
portfolio and then you multiply by row
which is kind of cool
so that's it so what it says is that um
that the optimal portfolio as a function
of required return
um is affine and that's got a fancy name
and finance i don't know why
they make it this complicated but anyway
or it's it's not that impressive frankly
but anyway
it's called uh the two fund they call it
the two fund theorem
and the reason is they're saying that
every optimal portfolio is a
is a combination of this fund right plus
this one
and you're like oh times row and you're
like okay whatever
fine cool but anyway it's interesting
what it says though is the risk return
curve is going to be on a straight line
now one end of the line which is zero
risk is simply the risk-free asset
okay so that's that's it you'll hear
this
okay so now we come and i want to make
it i've hinted at it a couple of times
but i want to make it super explicit
right
um that everything we're doing here
rests on something which i call
the big assumption i don't know why i
introduced the ba but anyway
maybe maybe it's because who knows we'll
see how many times i use that acronym
but
so here it is the big assumption is
basically future returns
will look something like past ones
now you know when you take another
course on statistics
and things like that then you can be you
could actually you can say this
uh more precisely if you'd like you'd
say something like or the statistics of
future returns
you know that come from this you know
look like the statistics of past ones or
whatever
but the truth is this is the assumption
essentially i mean it's vague it's not a
mathematical thing
what does it mean to say something looks
like something but that's the idea
okay now um that is the implicit
assumption
um now by the way every time you invest
you you sign something somewhere i
promise you
that that basically acknowledges that
you understand
that this is not the game so they say
things like you know whatever you know
past
performance is not a guarantee of future
blah blah blah
it's in some legal lease but every time
you invest
you know or if you open a brokerage fund
something like that
somewhere you sign something that
basically that makes you acknowledge
that the big assumption is in play
and that's basically so you don't go
back and sue them or something like that
okay all right fine um now it's
it's often reasonably true the big
assumption
um but actually there are times when it
is shockingly
not true and and people say they refer
to these as a
market shift or a a change in regime or
something like that
um and in those cases it's much less
true
um so just for example in the last year
we've
in the last two or three years we've had
you know stunning
crashes of the market followed by
incredible periods of growth and
more crap i don't it's it so it's um
and just looking at those your eyeball's
going to tell you going to remind you
that
that this need not be true um
however if it you know when it's true
while it's true i should say
um then it turns out a good weight
vector for past realized returns
should be good for future ones right
and so it would be an example you might
choose w based on the last
two years of returns and then use that
weight vector
for the next six months um so actually
people do much more sophisticated things
than that then they
they might re-do they might re they
might come up with a new w
daily and stuff like that but once you
get the basic ideas that we're talking
about
you would you would understand how to do
that and and how
and why people do that okay so that's
the big assumption
and you know honestly it's not um
it it's actually not that much different
from just data fitting
because that's you know if you ask a
statistician what are you doing i'm
fitting a model
you know how are you doing that you go
well i'm looking at all this past data
and i'm like but you don't need to
predict for past data if you know what
the outcome was
and they go yeah but i want to use it
for data i've never seen
and i'm like well why is it going to
work i mean
so basically they they also have a big
assumption
right and their big assumption is buried
in kind of mathematics and stuff like
that so you don't notice it
and basically started on page one you
know which was kind of like
well i'll assume that these things are
samples from some distribution
right and that's their way to be very
mathematically precise
about saying that well i think the
future data is going to look like the
past data
so okay enough on that
sorry the only one i'll say one one last
thing about that
the only thing you would say i would say
about that is this is it means
it means you know don't take any of the
models too seriously
right so that that that would be kind of
the uh the the takeaway message there
okay so let's look at an example um this
is 20 assets actually i think they're
like
etfs or something i can't remember what
that doesn't matter there's 20 assets
over 2000 days um
so that's eight years or something like
that it's 200 roughly you know roughly
eight years
um and here's what you get uh here here
they are in a risk
risk return plot so here's the
annualized return
um you know wow some of these are like
big earners right that's like
you know 18 return um now their their
volunteer
risk is pretty crazy too it's like 30 um
so and that makes sense i mean that
means that these things
you know over a year you could not
you shouldn't be surprised if they lose
10 percent and you shouldn't be
surprised if they return
40 which is pretty pretty high right so
that's what that means um let's see what
is that
i don't know what it is but i can i can
tell you from an investment point of
view
that is a super bad news uh asset right
there
uh because it is here's what it did it
over these eight years
uh it generated a really nice handsome
loss
um and it did so with extraordinary risk
so
okay uh so that's pretty good oh the
pareto optimal
uh assets would be the ones here
right probably in this picture it's just
these three sorry that's that one
okay so um probably it's this one too so
those would be the the pareto optimal
ones
meaning there is no single asset
in this group that dominates it and
dominates means has higher risk
and lower sorry lower risk and higher
return
so that those are the dots so there they
are it's rough roughly like that
let's see what these optimal portfolios
look like well there it is
okay so this line uh
shows you what the optimal portfolio how
they what their risk in return
is now this is on uh this is as we tune
the knob row right so if i set
uh in fact row is literally this number
right down
oh no no sorry my mistake that's row
right there
okay so um you know when we say it's i
i want an annualized return of 0.4 or i
want an annualized return
10 or 20 um that that's right over here
okay um and this is as i said it's a
line and
you know when you fiddle with row you
get that line okay
uh okay so um oh and over here
uh plotted in in dark is you see one of
the dark circles that's the one over end
portfolio
um actually it's not so bad right it's
kind of in the middle gives you a ten
percent return and uh whatever a 23
percent annualized
risk so okay and uh okay well people
would explain that by saying
that you have uh you know you've
diversified
and that you had your 20 assets and you
know in each
in each uh in each period some went up
some went down and the result was
the whatever end portfolio didn't go up
and down as much or something like that
okay so we're going to look at five
portfolios in fact
uh they're marked here um we're going to
ask for
10 20 that's this 10 20
and 40 that's extremely aggressive um
and uh we'll also look at one over n
here so here they are um oh and the
risk-free that's that's simple so
let's take a look at them and we'll look
at train and test so the way this
training was done on a period of eight
years
um and that was used that was how we got
the capital r matrix that's
that's where all the data came from and
out of that past data went into our
sausage making machine which is linearly
constrained least squares
and out came out came w okay
so uh that's that's that's what that is
now
let's look at some of the portfolios
here's one i guess the risk we return is
one percent
per year okay so um here
uh oh all of these the train will be
exactly the required number
because that's an equality constraint in
the uh in
our problem formulation right when we
when we say row is point
when we say row is 0.5 um 0.4 we mean
you have to do that so so the these are
exactly these numbers
um okay now the test is a different
thing
um the the return um and that's tested
on another
period of about two years that's a 500
day period
and but let's just look at them you know
so here they're
the risk-free by the way continues at
one percent right
the um row equals ten percent it says on
the test thing we get eight
uh that would be just fine i mean that
makes perfect sense right because
someone said hey
i thought you asked for ten percent you
go no let me be precise
i constructed a portfolio that on the
past eight years
would have made eight uh would have made
ten percent
exactly and you'd say why why would we
believe that on these two years it would
make
so ten but you know to eight percent is
close enough to ten that you'd say
that's cool
and and you can sort of look at these
and some of these kind of make sense
right so you can see that on the test
thing they made
different oh uh one big difference um
the uh
the uniform weights or one of our end
portfolio
um actually for whatever reason did uh
on those eight years and then 21 on the
test well this has to do with these
so-called regimes right where roughly
speaking things change
okay um let's look at the risk um so the
risk
is of course for risk-free it's it's
zero on train and test
oh and the leverage is one of course
it's one it's it's very long this is
very safe it's long only
um if we ask for ten percent um
this is sort of interesting the risk we
get
in train is .09 okay nine percent
um now on the test set you get seven
percent so that that's actually in your
favor i mean it's like
it's like okay but i mean this happened
this happens this is fine
right so uh it means that it was less
you had less risk on that two year
period than the eight than the eighth
period
eight year period on which w on the
basis of which
is how we chose w um and if you look up
here you know for rho equals 20
you would get a risk you know you
you made a risk a risk you you got a
return of 20
on test it was 15 um the risk you got
was about
point 18 and then on the test it was
pretty
somehow the test period is clearly a
little bit more benign or something like
that
and you're ready but it's in the
ballpark and you'd expect this so these
are all the kind of things you would
you would sort of uh you you'd sort of
guess
uh would happen right so so this just
shows you how you do this
let's take a look at the portfolio value
of these five portfolios
um oh and please note the plot right so
two thousand this is about eight years
here um so um
it's eight years right so and we start
with you know ten thousand that's the
traditional number and you know look um
i mean this is crazy how you know this
the the black one is insane that's the
that's when we're super risky and we've
got
uh oh i should go back and say something
about the leverage the leverage is like
5.48 so so
that's that means you're it means that
for basically like every dollar of value
in your portfolio your
absolute value position is like 5.48
it's
i mean it's a fair amount of leverage
that this place is
operating with higher leverage than that
usually i might add with other people's
money
that's that's that's the best way to run
a leveraged uh portfolio is
have other other people's money oh and
make sure you have a passport to a
a uh a country with no extradition
treaty with the u.s that would be the
other
two tips well okay i digress let's go
back to this
um okay so uh so this is kind of
extraordinary right like uh
even 50 would have been pretty good
that's that's a 5x return
over this eight year period um so
and you can see that this uh the green
one that's the 20 that's one where we
ask for 20
you know kind of gets there um let's see
oh you can barely see the blue one going
up because the risk-free rate i think we
set was one percent
um and then you can see several other
things um for example the ten percent
uh value one when we ask for ten percent
um you can see that it well and yeah it
goes up and
does pretty well ten percent per year
times eight years you know it's
maybe going to double in size or so
roughly right and that's about what it
is maybe
maybe less than that but okay um and
then here's the one over n portfolio
that's the
the the red um actually what's kind of
cool is
somewhere in the range of of day 1200 to
1300 or
something it's been i don't know was
that
three years it's been three four years
it's been four years
um five years right right around five
years someone says hey how's your one of
run portfolio doing the answer is
you've actually lost money compared to
where you started four years ago
okay none of the others do that um so
and then here it is on test
so the the test is running over 500 days
this is this crazy insane super
aggressive thing
and sure enough here's the test it
starts up at you started 10 000
you go down to i don't know that's
that's pushing on the left
so you drop value by 10 that's called a
draw down that's a good slang term to
know
so your portfolio immediately went down
ten percent then
shot up down up down up down this kind
of thing so
um and that's actually what that's what
risk means is the port valley for
portfolio values shooting up and down
and stuff like that so by the way if you
have a stomach for
uh this kind of roller coaster ride then
fine
and you can look at the others and they
do they do just what you think they
would do
oh uh i should say i i mean i should
admit
the one of our end thing ends up doing
pretty well i guess i mean it's got
pretty high risk but it does pretty well
okay so this is sort of an introduction
to this topic uh you can take an entire
class
on nothing but this you can take
multiple classes on other aspects of
finance
um i should also mention a couple of
things you know this um
it's easy to think of general you know
uh things you would do next uh
for example people update the weights
every single day
sometimes by just solving another
problem like this um
another thing not you know not that's
out of the scope of this class is you
can add constraints on the weights
um and later maybe you'll take a class
on convex optimization and you'll see
how
linearly constrained least squares can
be extended to include
inequality constraints so that's also
something that would that that you'd see
uh in you know later uh well you see a
lot of stuff later
um maybe the mo the the principle thing
you'd see later is this is that uh
people who
do this think entirely in terms of
statistics so
my friends who do finance can't even
believe that here i am
explaining a little bit about portfolio
optimization with no statistics and you
will notice we didn't have any
statistics
however is very very close once you
learn the statistics and stuff like that
it'd be the same things the same
formulas it's identical
the only difference is that they're
giving an interpretation statistically
okay so that's our that's our first uh
application of
constrained least squares